hundreds of farmers and Indigenous
people clash with police early on
Thursday they have attacked an oil field
in a rural area of San Vicente Del
caguan in southern Colombia
protesters have burned the offices and
other infrastructure of the field owned
by International Oil Company Emerald
energy
a police officer and a protester have
been killed allegedly by gunshots the
community then detained at least 79
police officers and nine Oil Workers
they were forced to march in a line
while being mocked by the demonstrators
Ombudsman repudiated the violence
we regret the confrontational situation
that left a police officer and the
farmer dead and many injured violent
acts only create more violence and don't
ease the path towards spaces of dialogue
between the people to find agreement
pensions has been rising in the area for
over a month as communities blocked
access to the oil field demanding
improvements to local roads and other
infrastructure
region has long been a focus of conflict
dissidents factions of Colombia's former
fact Rebels operate in the region and
may be involved in the unrest
in a tweet president Gustavo Petro has
ordered that the violent stop
dispatching a joint commission from
Colombia's defense and interior
Ministries as well as the armed forces
to the region but opposition politicians
in an attack against the government say
the unrest is a consequence of Petro's
failing security policies that favor
dialogue and negotiations with criminal
elements
what's happening today is the
consequence of the lack of prisons in
action of the national government we are
going back to the time when criminals
took control of Colombia's territory
late on Thursday the officers remain
hostages as the government scrambles to
bring the situation under control
Alessandra and pieti Al Jazeera